[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir mes chers enfants
ouf quel style ans je me demande ce que
font nicolas et pimprenelle ils ont
l'air très calme ce soir tombe le jeu
descend vite lors du rebond soir pourvu
qu'il ne me prépare pas une blague
ma petite seule la bataille est la maman
d'accord moi je suis le matin et moi ma
maman
boussois voilà notre grande et égaux
soir grande et des noces voulez-vous me
dire pourquoi vous m'appelez bébé parce
qu'on joue au papa et à la maman au loup
message à ses toits sur ta petite chef
nord comme ça ne bouge pas mon bébé
maman revient demain q ha bon ah non
leur pas bébé elle est allée faire des
coups le jeu de leur peau chérif monde
était a été sa trust al mabhouh
ana j'ai une surprise pour lui
je sens que je vais être pas pu trancher
[Musique]
requins de papa comme notre fils est
mignon un vrai petit coche hallo trust
avec maman bébé papa va travailler ou
revoir papa et leur maman des pays bas
bavard mais je pleure pas tu peux
réparer un peu même pour jouer avait
déjà clairement son papa sera alors je
pleure je pleure pas c'est pas manquer
père bon sauveur voilà je me teins
qu'est ce qu'ils ont dans ce petit
bonhomme enchérit cyclo maman tiens mon
gros dp vraiment beau laurent ces deux
longs solos qui fait un bébé qu'est ce
qui se passe ici tu fais bien d'harry
redknapp un bébé est très humain il a
refusé de boire son biberon et il a
chaté sotomo bon allant bébé tu ne veux
pas que papa te donne une fessée qu'en
mars au dos à la voix vibre ou tient aux
longs mois j'ai joué mon bébé et je le
dirai aux marques comme ça merci patron
vous m'avez sauvé annonce jacky nous on
veut te dire bonsoir
tu sais on jouait tout à l'heure et tu
es si mignon en bébé bon c'est fini
la jette à la lumière bonne nuit nous
bogny petite robe bleu bonnet enfants à
te voilà mon gros bébé je ne suis pas de
bulle patron alors enlève ton bonnet se
pâment arrow de 3 pb à lons en route
vieux compagnons je le sors bonne nuit
les petits
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]